hello there welcome to the heavy
spoilers show i'm your host paul and
this video we're breaking down the
obi-wan trailer first fact obi-wan is
short for obi-wan kenobi r2 is short for
r2d2 and luke skywalker is short for a
stormtrooper
for more craft facts like that make sure
you stay locked into the video as we're
going to be breaking down all the easter
eggs hidden details and things you
missed in the new look make sure you
smash your thumbs up button and also
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the obi-wan kenobi trailer
okay so obi-wan kenobi has a lot going
on with it and personally i think it's
going to be the biggest star wars disney
plus show we've had the mandalorian
which was a completely unknown character
and this was then followed by the book
of boba fett though he's got a strong
following and i love the guy he wasn't
one of the major major characters
whereas obi-wan was a pretty big part of
the prequel and original trilogy this is
the first massive character we've had a
show for and to build upon this hayden
christensen will be returning as darth
vader though it somewhat contradicts the
line about when they last met in a new
hope i'm sure they can work around it
and the kenobi show is gonna fill in a
lot of the blanks between revenge of the
sith and that film now obi-wan will
begin on tatooine a handful of years
after he dropped luke off at his aunt
and uncles amongst the dunes he watched
over young skywalker and this has been
explored in some of the comics which may
inspire some of the episodes we've known
for some time now due to concept art
that at some point he'll ride an eop and
if you cast your mind back to the end of
revenge of the sith you'll remember that
he rode one then too
[Music]
the fight is done
we lost
now we could to him very much having to
live a lowly life and whereas he was
once revered by many he's down on his
luck we can see a line of people queuing
up and later he's on a transport which
is very reminiscent of the great
depression when people used to have to
line up for work and also food he says
the fight is done and that they lost and
from here we occur to him overlooking
owen lars's farm where we can catch and
peru and also a young luke with the
goggles on he very much looks like how
anakin did in the prequel trilogy when
he went pod racing and it's some awesome
iconography this actually also feels
like it was ripped right from the comics
in a moment in which obi-wan looked over
luke
[Music]
stay hidden
now one of the major aspects in the
comics that will likely get fleshed out
in the series is that obi-wan basically
put survival above being a jedi what i
mean by that is that the character would
see injustices and most eyesightly but a
lot of the time he wouldn't be able to
intervene in the comics from the
journals of obi-wan kenobi luke came
across his diaries and these expanded on
his life on the planet after the fall of
the order he had to very much lie low
and hide who he was because as we know
there are inquisitors that are on the
hunt for him you also know that joel
edgerton will be reprising the role of
owen laws in the series and if we look
at the comics we can kind of speculate
what sort of role his character will
play in the books obi-wan knew that he
should really be training luke and
though this could put him in danger it
would better prepare him for if his
father ever managed to find him obi-wan
knew that the temptation of the sith was
very powerful and that if he hadn't been
trained in the ways of the jedi first
that he would instantly give into it now
on the other side of this was owen who
didn't want luke getting involved in any
of the drama after obi wan sent luke a
gift owen actually angrily returned it
to him and told him to stay out of
luke's life however owen did somewhat
come to appreciate him after obi-wan
saved the pair from black cressentine
you'll likely remember him from the book
of boba fett and i think they purposely
introduced the character there so that
it's way more impactful when he shows up
in the series now the story around this
is that jabber started running an
extortionate war attacks on moisture
farmers in the area obi-wan put a stop
to this and chris santon was sent out by
jabba to find the man who'd cut off some
of his income chrysanthemum took owen
hostage to draw obi-wan out and the pair
ended up fighting each other obi-wan won
i'll be one and a crescendo ended up
fleeing the planet for some time which i
think would be an awesome storyline to
drop into the series
[Music]
the key
to hunting jedi
this patience
next we go to the lucasfilm logo and you
can catch some sand drifting in over the
top of it which is of course
representative of tatooine from here we
jump to the grand inquisitor the leader
of the jedi hunting group that has
appeared in several aspects of the
expanded lore he's not alone and if you
look in the corner you can also catch
another member of the group who i
believe shows up later on in the trailer
i'm not 100 on who this is but i think
it's fit brother who is one of the many
inquisitors that we get a look at later
on we're introduced to inquisitor eva
and initially when the sizzle reel first
dropped a lot of people thought that
this might be the second sister from
fallen order
jedi cannot help what they are
their compassion
leaves a trail
sith inquisitors were basically four
sensitive people that were enlisted by
vader and palpatine to hunt down the
jedi throughout the galaxy they're
constantly on the search and they'll do
whatever they can to make sure that
order 66 is carried out to completion
she's clearly stalking tatooine and
there have been several images of her
release through entertainment weekly
that show her talking to own laws we
know very little about her and it is
possible that the seventh sister may
appear too she did show up in rebels and
there was very little known about her so
i think she'd make for a great character
to pop up in the season two there's a
lot of theories that the seventh sister
is barrosofi who was potentially teased
in the grogu flashback of order 66. i'm
a bit unsure whether that's the case but
with it being a popular fan theory i
thought it was worth bringing up due to
the architecture here it seems like it's
tatooine and we see riva on the planet
so it makes sense now we also get shots
of several of them together and on the
back of one you can see the lightsabers
they typically tend to use which has a
circular handle now at this point we see
some stormtroopers and you'll notice
that they're now in the fully classic
uniform as opposed to the clone one in
the bad batch we watched as the empire
ended up phasing out the cameron owens
and at the end of the series they
destroyed topoka city the empire
realized that it's much much cheaper for
them to just invade a planet and force
the people there into conscription but
with this comes a lack of skill which is
why the stormtroopers couldn't even hit
that like button if the world's worst
youtube channel told them to from here
we jump to the inquisitors happily
publicly executing all those that could
potentially harbour jedi lars is clearly
worried by this as he of course knows
luke is the son of darth vader and i
can't wait to see the showdowns that
they have i was from this point that we
catch the inquisitors and obi-wan on the
planet daru in an interview with
entertainment weekly writer joby harold
said it's got this sort of hong kong
feel to it the planet is graffiti laden
full of neon signs and it's very
captivating to look at there's a chase
across the sky and obi-wan even uses a
blaster at one point which of course
said in revenge was a primitive weapon
he releases some birds to cause a
distraction and then we get the words
hope survives which is of course playing
on a new hope and the trailer ends with
vader's breathing and though he's not in
the first look he will be in the show
[Music]
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they play this as we know from the
established canon that he wasn't aware
of luca leia at this point in his life
it was only after the destruction of the
death star that he learned luke was his
son and this of course pissed the guy
off massively as pulps had told him
padme died because he killed her in
anger however she actually died of a
broken heart
after she gave birth to the twins now
this was something that palpatine didn't
tell him as he suspected that his
children could lead him away from being
his minion and also because he was
probably embarrassed by how bad the
writing of dying of a broken heart was
now both the sith and yet i realized
that if people have attachments to
others that it can end up clouding their
judgment and much like how ahsoka didn't
want mando to see grogu pulps didn't
want vader to learn about his kids this
is also why he didn't return to tatooine
to look for them as he simply didn't
know that they existed also yet side
tangent i love that obi-wan had anywhere
in the galaxy to hide luke and he left
him with his uncle i know i know there's
actual reasons behind it but i always
just find it kind of funny and yeah let
me laugh yeah i haven't slept for more
than an hour at a time since my kids
were born now vader not knowing about
them is something i don't think they
will wreck on because this lie was a
major factor in why vader wanted to
overthrow the emperor with luke his
palace on mustafar will also be
appearing in the series which we saw in
rogue one vader built it on the planet
because he was somewhat born there i
think we'll stop by at several points in
the season hopefully we get lots of
scenes where he's in the back the tank
because as we know everyone loves that
now this series is all gonna build
towards a massive showdown between vader
and obi-wan which was first teased at in
the concept dot this is basically what
everyone wants to see and i'm so hyped
to watch this play out we kind of
already know that vader has to lose it
and then that still keeps things in line
with a bit about him still being a
learner in a new hope now a big
character i've not really seen mention
in any of the leaks reports or info on
the show is emperor palpatine if darth
vader is showing up then it makes sense
that pulps would too i don't really like
the rise of skywalker that much but you
know what star wars is like they tend to
do something terrible and then spend the
next 10 years explaining it so that you
actually grow to love it i didn't really
like the prequel trilogy all that much
when it first came out but thanks to
clone wars i enjoy it way more and i
think that they could do something like
this with the palpatine clone story we
did get a tease towards this in the
mandalorian season too and if they
expanded on it in this one i think it
would at least help with some of the
criticisms that i have with the last
star wars movie it would offer a ray of
new hope at the finish which is a very
popular hey having that now as with my
thoughts on the trailer it's got me
really hyped for what's to come and it
seems like this is the series where
they're bringing out all the big guns as
i mentioned earlier all the prior series
was centered around characters that were
either brand new or ones that only
really got expanded on in the clone wars
and rebels series here though we have a
major character from the prequels and
original trilogy and there's also of
course darth vader coming back hayden
returning is a massive get for the
series and i can't wait to see how the
new show flashes out not only obi-wan's
life but also vader's gonna make for a
really interesting series in my opinion
and i'm hyped for its release when it
drops in may now until then i'd love to
hear your thoughts so make sure you
comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day on screen right now we have a
breakdown of the batman which i think is
one of the best videos that we've ever
done on the channel not better than this
crap and hopefully i'll see you over
there after this but if not then thanks
for singing through the video i'll be
ball you've been the best i'll see on
the next one take care peace